hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to discuss the fox space
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
the very first postulate of quantum
mechanics tells us that all the action
happens in a vector space called the
state space in many situations all we
need to consider is a fixed number of
particles
in this context we've been discussing
how to work with state spaces for a
fixed number of particles
ranging from one-dimensional problems
all the way to multi-particle systems
where we had to consider tensor product
state spaces
today i want to take this one step
further and introduce the state space
that allows us to consider a variable
number of particles
this state space is called the fox space
named after vladimir [ __ ]
it is the space in which quantum
mechanics happens when we work in the
second quantization
formalism and it plays a major role in
areas ranging from quantum field theory
to quantum statistical mechanics so
let's go
today's video is mostly about
definitions but bear with me because
they are quite specific and it is easy
to get them mixed up
consider a system of n identical quantum
particles whose states are given in the
occupation number representation
by listing the number of particles in
each single particle state
as written here remember that this means
that we consider a particular single
particle base is u
and there are n1 particles in state u1
n2 particles in state u2
and so on so in general we have nk
particles in state uk
the total number of particles in the
system is capital n
obtained by summing over all occupation
numbers
states like this one up here have
well-defined occupation numbers
given by the nk values and have a
well-defined total number of particles
given by the capital n states with a
well-defined number of particles are
called foc
states you will remember from the video
on the symmetrization postulate that for
bosons
the state space to which these fox
states belong to is made of totally
symmetric kets of n particles
and we call this subspace v plus
for fermions the state space to which
the fox states belong to
is made of totally anti-symmetric heads
of n particles
and we call it v minus
we will represent the collective state
space of a system of identical particles
whether it is made of bosons or fermions
by a calligraphic f with a capital n sub
index
indicating the total number of particles
n in the system
for example f1 is the state space of a
single particle
f2 is the state space of two particle
systems
and so on and importantly for what
follows we're also going to define f0
as the space containing zero particles
we're now ready to define the fog space
we write it with a calligraphic f
without any sub-index
and it is the state space formed by the
direct sum of the state spaces
associated with zero particles
one particle two particles and so on
first a quick refresher of direct sums
of vector spaces
for the vector space v p of dimension p
and the second one v q of dimension q
then the direct sum of v p and v q
is another vector space of dimension p
plus two
if p is a vector in v p and
q is a vector in v q then the direct sum
space is spanned by all linear
combinations of a vector from space vp
and one from space vq as such
a basis for v p plus q is simply
obtained by combining the individual
bases for vp
and vq so what does this mean for the
fox space
it is the space spanned by the
occupation number states for all
possible numbers of particles
as such we can form a basis of the fox
space by combining the bases of all
individual
fn spaces another important point is
that by construction
two cats with different numbers of
particles are orthogonal to each other
remembering that the fox state has a
fixed number of particles
then we see that the fox state is simply
a state that belongs to a subspace fn
of the fox space as we will see in many
other videos
a very important fox state is the
so-called vacuum state which corresponds
to zero particles
we denote it by a bracket with a label
zero and it is the state belonging to
the one-dimensional state space
f0
the power of fox space is that it allows
us to go beyond
the fixed number of particles that fox
states describe
we can do that by forming linear
superpositions of states corresponding
to different numbers of particles
a simple example is this state here in
which i am using the simplified notation
where we only include the occupation
numbers of the occupied states
apart from the vacuum state which is
always zero
so in this language this is a state that
is a superposition state of the vacuum
state
a single particle state and a two
particle state in which the two
particles occupy two different states
the state has some amplitude of having
zero particles
some of having one particle and some of
having two particles
a state like this one is a very clear
example of how folk space allows us to
treat systems with a variable number of
particles
so to finish let's ask again why do we
care about fox space
there are two main reasons the first is
that it provides a very natural language
to describe physical situations in which
there is a variable number of particles
the two best known examples of this are
on the one hand quantum field theory
the relativistic theory of quantum
mechanics where for example we have
creation and annihilation of particles
and anti-particles
and on the other hand quantum
statistical mechanics where a system can
be in equilibrium with a particle
reservoir
with which it exchanges particles and is
described within the grand canonical
ensemble
the second is a more practical reason
fox space is a very useful mathematical
tool to describe systems with a fixed
number of particles
in which during the calculation we may
allow for the number of particles to
change
but at the end of the calculation we
always recover the fixed number of
particles we started with
in this context foxspace provides a very
natural language to study systems of
identical particles this is because the
resulting mathematics is much
simpler when compared to the many terms
that one has to deal with
if we instead use the symmetrized
permanence or anti-symmetrized slate
determinants
that i introduced in the video on the
symmetrization postulate
very last thing i want to mention is
that given the structure of fox space
it will be essential to study the
operators that allow us to change the
number of particles
as these operators will allow us to
navigate the fox space
these operators are called creation and
annihilation operators for obvious
reasons
and i encourage you to check out the
corresponding videos linked in the
description
putting together the occupation number
representation in fox space with these
operators
forms the basis of the formalism known
as second quantization
the fox space provides the platform on
which we can do quantum mechanics when
the number of particles isn't fixed
as such it underpins areas such as
quantum field theory where we have
creation and annihilation of particles
and anti-particles or quantum
statistical mechanics where our system
can exchange particles with a reservoir
so now that we know about the structure
of the fog space the next thing we need
to do is to learn how to navigate this
fox space
and for that you should check the videos
on the creation and annihilation
operators
of both bosons and fermions if you liked
the video or like send me suggestions
for future videos
please subscribe